-This is really cool --
your parents are backstage.
-Yeah.
-They flew out from Australia
because you've got
two premieres this week.
You have this film, and then,
you have a film, "Gringo,"
that you're in, that
your brother, Nash, directed,
which is really cool.
And you guys have
worked together over the years,
but this is the first time,
obviously, he's directed
a big American movie.
How was that?
-It was awesome.
I mean,
as Nash said the other day,
he's been bossing me around
and directing me
since I was, like, a kid.
-Yeah.
-And then we both get paid
to live out that same dynamic.
-Yeah.
-And he did a great job.
We played the movie
in Miami the other night.
It went down like crazy.
It's about a guy
who gets kidnapped in Mexico,
a guy who works for
a pharmaceutical corporation.
Charlize Theron and I
play these corporate jerks,
which is strangely easy to play.
[ Laughter ]
For Charlize.
Bigger stretch for me.
And -- And it was --
It's amazing.
And I really encourage everybody
to go see...all of my movies.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, well, I want to say,
'cause we've talked about
your brother before.
You're also
a wonderful director,
and I know you're working
on something else right now.
-Yes, I am.
[ Laughter ]
-Your brother, though --
Like, a lot of actors direct.
Your brother is a stunt man.
-Well, he started as a stunt guy
and then became an editor
and then a director.
-So I guess what
I'm saying is, like,
you went from actor to director.
I've heard about that before.
Your brother,
that's kind of mind-blowing.
If there's someone
I'm impressed with...
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
You know, stunt man...
Actor, director.
-Well, if you go
from nail salon to director,
that would be slightly more...
No, he is
a very impressive director.
My brother -- and I hate
to pay him a compliment
on live TV,
but I'm going to look down
the barrel of the camera.
Pretty much anything he puts his
mind to, he does very well.
-That's fantastic,
and so lucky that you guys
get to work together.
I'm very --
I'm very jealous of that.
I want to close,
because we've done this before.
You've been on the show --
I think this is the fourth time,
and we've busted you
on some outfits.
-Yeah.
-The last time you were here,
I pointed out,
these are two different times
you were wearing this sweat --
[ Laughter ]
And it's literally like
you're going out, thinking,
"I hope someone takes a picture
for the next time
I'm on 'Late Night.'"
[ Laughter ]
And yet here you go.
You're out again --
This was the latest.
You're on a beach.
I guess, based on the hat,
in the middle of winter.
[ Laughter ]
-No wonder
I would make a terrible spy.
[ Laughter ]
"No one's gonna see me.
No one's gonna..."
I'm wearing
the same sweater, right?
-But, you know,
I thought you were,
but then, look --
it's a slightly different logo.
[ Laughter ]
So you've got a new one.
-When you are sponsored...
-You're sponsored?
-...they update you.
[ Laughter ]
-But you're trying to strip me
of my sponsorship here
by ridiculing me.
-They sponsored you,
and they were so good with this,
they said, "We've got
to give him a new one?"
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I promise you, next time
I come on your show, I'm just
gonna wear one of these outfits.
-Please!
-Forget all this.
-Yeah. Forget this.
This isn't the real Joel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It doesn't feel like me.
-I want to meet the real Joel.
-All right.
I can't wait.
-The real Joel is coming.
-Always such a pleasure
to talk to you.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on everything.